from cold-blooded murder to toxic Mind
Games Yellowstone has it all but it's
complicated so grab your cowboy hat and
get ready because we're taking a look at
the Yellowstone scenes that didn't age
well
in the season 2 episode Resurrection Day
the level of violence we become
accustomed to on Yellowstone Rises to a
new level as the only daughter of the
duttons Beth is known for her bold
personality which usually takes the form
of fiery comebacks and an abrasive
attitude it's almost a surprise then
when she's attacked at her office as Rip
desperately tries to reach Beth before
it's too late two masked men sent by
Malcolm Beck storming the premises
hoping to scare her all that tough talk
Beth
I've got the cure for that
we'll see how tough you are after I give
it to him what's most notable about this
scene is just how violent it is a
fearful Beth is left bloodied and
vulnerable in the grip of both men
that's not to say she doesn't fight back
she tries to gouge their eyes out and
throws them through glass walls the
fight is a testament to the fact that
Yellowstone is willing to go there but
also that it can take its grittiness too
far what's more it doesn't send a great
message about violence against women
although it's commendable to show what
can actually happen so explicitly it's
also a straight up brutal watch
the most heartbreaking moment comes when
Beth lets herself cry the tough gritty
exterior she spent a lifetime building
up temporarily broken
there are a few people who Inspire more
fear on the ranch than Lloyd Pierce he
might even outstrip the infamously
brutal rip wheeler in this department in
the season 4 episode winning or learning
the stage is set for an incredibly
questionable brawl with rip setting
Lloyd against Walker while Lloyd
maintains the upper hand the pair go for
round two a few episodes later with
Lloyd beating Walker to a pulp in the
middle of the ranch to teach Lloyd a
lesson rip smashes his hand with the
boot though it's unsurprising to see a
Yellowstone brawl in such gory detail it
doesn't age well within the big picture
of Rip's character development
violent Outburst is his own fault
something he quickly seems to realize as
he leaves Lloyd bleeding there's no
fighting on this Ranch you want to fight
somebody you come fight me I'll fight
you all day beyond the brutality lies
the question of whether or not this
lesson is necessary or if rip overdid it
even though the fight sets rip up for a
juicy Redemption Arc it does a
disservice to the storylines in
relationship that come before it though
uncomfortable scenes often contain great
messages that doesn't make them any
easier to watch
in the season 3 episode I killed a man
today Monica finds herself in trouble
after catching a ride with a known
Predator after trying to persuade her to
leave the vehicle to get better phone
service he becomes violent and
forcefully restrains her on the ground
but Monica has put herself in the line
of fire in the name of a sting a sniper
swiftly brings the Predator to his
arguably deserved end while it's
admirable for Yellowstone to take on the
issue of violence against indigenous
women the scene has some questionable
side effects
simply put it's terrible to watch and
the scene reinforces the idea that women
need to relive their trauma for the sake
of the greater good Monica is visibly
shaken by what she's gone through she's
strong but even the most rock-solid
person would be rattled by such an
encounter opening up emotional wounds is
commonplace on Yellowstone but it could
perhaps be handled more sensitively
as far as the Yellowstone Universe goes
Sheriff Donnie Haskell wasn't a major
player throughout the first four seasons
his questionable morals and alliance
with the Dutton family often Fade Into
the background that being said his
sudden death takes viewers by surprise
and leads to moments that are
excruciating to watch in no kindness for
the coward John and rip get involved in
a Diner Hold Up mid robbery John storms
in from the back kitchen to try and take
out the thieves and Dani gets caught in
the crossfire taking a fatal blow to the
throat to make matters worse Dani tries
to call his daughter only managing to
get a few words out before he dies John
has left to tell Donny's daughter what's
happened the final moments of the scene
are incredibly intense and especially
hard to watch for anyone who suddenly
lost a loved one and afterward audiences
are left with the knowledge that Donny's
death could have been prevented if Jon
and rip hadn't gotten involved is the
scene just a case of someone playing the
hero for their own reasons if so that's
seriously perhaps unnecessarily
wrenching
like the montagues and capulets of Romeo
and Juliet the ongoing war between the
duttons and backs is never ending it's
also a linchpin of the Yellowstone story
I'm not gonna lose this one
by the time fans get to season two sins
of the Father the feud is well
established many of the backs have met a
grisly end at the hands of the duns but
no death is more unnecessary or
confusing than Teal's sudden demise
as Casey sneaks into his house he finds
an unsuspecting teal on the toilet and
shoots him as Casey watches him die he
tells teal he promised his wife to kill
him in the most humiliating way possible
as far as humiliation goes the scene
hits the nail on the head the whole
sequence is awkward and excruciating to
watch not to mention fairly irrelevant
to the bigger story there's no doubt
teal brought this misery on himself but
couldn't he die with dignity intact
somewhere between funny and hard-hitting
the scene finds itself in an emotional
no man's land that leaves viewers
confused and embarrassed
sibling rivalry is at the heart of any
good family drama but the tension
between Beth and Jamie is unique the
intensity of their hatred is palpable
from the very first episode but the
reason behind it isn't revealed in
season 3's Cowboys and dreamers in a
flashback sequence teenage Beth confides
in Jaime that she needs to hide a
pregnancy Jaime takes her out of town
for an abortion but neglects to mention
that it will leave her infertile you
don't want to do this here
a requirement of patients receiving an
abortion at this Clinic
sterilization it goes without saying
that exploring pregnancy and abortion on
TV is going to be contentious regardless
in the eyes of many viewers this scene
takes things too far
some fans find the storyline outright
insulting while some medical
professionals take issue with its
inaccuracy it doesn't take long for
Yellowstone to establish exactly what
kind of show it is in the opening
moments of the pilot audiences are
introduced to John Dutton currently in
the middle of trying to protect his
Ranch from Land developers a stream of
blood runs down Jon's face as he tries
to comfort a suffering horse then puts
it out of its misery
we later learned that it's all a result
of a nasty traffic accident there's
something about seeing an animal suffer
that hits extra hard things we lose to
keep you fed
[Music]
Yellowstone stars have had to clarify
that the show doesn't abuse animals but
Peta has actively encouraged viewers to
boycott the show for some viewers the
opening scene is a questionable
introduction to the series as a whole
when it comes to Rip's wrath on
Yellowstone No One Is Safe
characters take their well-being into
their own hands when they decide to
cross the Dutton family and season 3's
meaner than evil shows just how terrible
the consequences can be
that's so much has something belongs to
me and I want it back
as the major antagonists across multiple
Seasons Wade Morrow quickly loses the
respect of the family especially once
he's accused of stealing after betraying
the duttons in their Ranch Wade is
Tracked Down by rip and murdered in the
middle of nowhere as a branded worker
Wade also has his brand cut off before
his body is dumped Yellowstone routinely
pushes the boundaries for what can be
shown on cable TV but this scene might
just take the biscuit viewers without
the stomach for Gore will definitely
need to look away as close-ups of the
brand removal paired with Wade's painful
cries in the knife sound effects are a
lot to take mister I don't know you if
you're wearing that brand you must be a
bad man
you must be even worse even though the
series is set in the present day the
violence feels uncomfortably
old-fashioned bordering on barbaric as
arguably the most agonizing death in
Yellowstone so far this scene is one of
the show's most shocking moments
in season two's blood the boy after
Jaime tries to recant his statement
while cooperating with Sarah's campaign
to expose corruption on the Dutton Ranch
the two find themselves alone you're not
the First Source to have second thoughts
but
we're way past that point things quickly
get ugly Sarah tells him that his family
deserves to lose everything and Jaime is
enraged in a fury he smashes Sarah's
head into the roof of their nearby car
as if that wasn't bad enough he finishes
the job off by strangling Sarah as she
lies helplessly on the ground although
it goes without saying that Sarah
doesn't deserve to die the way Jaime
goes about killing her makes the
situation even worse with a chilling
stare Jimmy leans into his dark side
with no hesitation I'm so sorry he
repeats as he strangles Sarah but does
that matter in fact the dialogue makes
it even more uncomfortable to watch no
matter what he's saying Jaime commits a
horrific Act
by the time viewers get to season three
there's just one catastrophe missing
from the dutton's lives a
life-threatening explosion the episode
the world is purple delivers that
missing link with Beth's assistant
losing her life by opening a package
that also sets Beth's office Ablaze the
hit on the Dutton family doesn't stop
there Casey narrowly escapes being
gunned down while Jon is nearly the
victim of a drive-by shooting it's
incredible that any family member
survive the episode let alone all of
them but while the action might seem
far-fetched it's the gratuitous deaths
that call this scene into question in
the case of Beth's office it doesn't
make much sense for her assistant to be
killed off not only does her loss seem
completely unnecessary it also puts the
spotlight back on the show's tendency to
depict extreme violence against women if
the creators wanted this episode to have
Maximum Impact surely a dud needed to be
lost along the way
context tells us everything and when it
comes to the Dutton family a lot needs
to be unpacked in order to understand
their dysfunctional relationships a
hefty chunk of Yellowstone season 5 is
devoted to digging into the family's
history with the episode The Dream is
not me focusing on John dutton's rise to
the top while Jon doesn't really change
throughout the series we learn how his
toxic personality has infected rip who
has never been able to lie to him
teenage rip was at odds with the boy
called Rowdy over Beth around the same
time he knocks Rowdy to the ground with
the boulder truly copying the behavior
he's grown up around all his life in
essence this is the master class on how
to be a terrible person though
Yellowstone features plenty of rough and
tumble guys toxic masculinity is likely
not a character Choice that's going to
age well I feel like I shouldn't be
watching but I can't stop riveting not
only do viewers see rip forced to make a
choice that could have easily been
avoided but Jon is also complicit
because he gave rip the brand that set
him on a path of no return though the
relationship between the pair is
undoubtedly interesting Rip's choice to
murder Rowdy and the way he does does it
is perhaps an unnecessary addition to
the problems that are already woven into
the show
if you or anyone you know has been a
victim of sexual assault help is
available visit the rape abuse and
incest National Network website or
contact Reigns National helpline at
1-800-656-hope 4673
foreign